la lucha contra el narcotráfico pone
tambalear las relaciones entre Estados
Unidos y México en una sesión del comité
del senado estadounidense el secretario
de estado Anthony blinken aseguró que
parte del territorio mexicano está
controlado Por los carteles de la droga
y que las acciones para contrarrestar su
tráfico deben ser mayores un objetivo
para el que no descartó catalogará las
bandas mexicanas como terroristas qué
tal esta idea en vez de solo intervenir
en la frontera vamos a la raíz y
declaramos a los carteles como
organizaciones terroristas bajo la ley
estadounidense lo consideraría sí
ciertamente lo consideraríamos una
afirmación que matizó al anotar que
México ha incautado cantidades récords
de fentanilo y sentenció que ambos
países están colaborando muy de cerca
las declaraciones sin embargo no fueron
bien tomadas por varios sectores de la
sociedad mexicana por lo que el
canciller del país intentó calmar los
ánimos Marcelo ebrard dijo que blinken
se encontraba en una encrucijada y dada
por el senador republicano Lindsay
graham quien cuestionó al secretario de
estado durante la audiencia
una actitud mediadora que contrasta con
la del presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador quien elevó el tono al
criticar las acusaciones de violaciones
de derechos humanos de Estados Unidos a
su país se creen el gobierno del mundo
se asumen
como el gobierno del mundo
nada más decir que no es cierto que son
unos mentirosos según el gobierno
mexicano del país incautado más de seis
toneladas de fentanilo en los últimos
meses en operativos que han causado la
muerte de 75 agentes de sus fuerzas de
seguridad